et on est d'abord avec vous stéphanie
gibeau vous êtes auteur de la traque des
lanceurs d'alert préface est justement
par julian assange est peut-être que
paul thompson vice-président du parti
conservateur britannique en france nous
rejoindra bonsoir avoue stéphanie ribot
comme cela vient d'être détaillé les
dernières informations donc indique que
le gouvernement de theresa may la
première ministre elle même à l'époque
se trouverait derrière l'arrestation de
julian assange est ce que vous êtes
surpris par ces révélations
vous savez au point où on en est au bout
de dix ans je crois que malheureusement
plus j'veux plus rien on est surprenant
ce qui est peut-être plus surprenant ce
serait de savoir qui est derrière qui
est derrière ça c'est à dire à qui
thierry zabé et son gouvernement aurait
obéi et quelles auraient été les
intérêts pour que justement ils sortent
dieu d'une absence de l'ambassade de
l'équateur
il faut il faut rappeler quand même que
pendant que tu n'as sans j'étais à
l'ambassade d'équateur le le
gouvernement britannique a payé des
policiers qui surveillaient l'ambassade
et jour et nuit je n'ai plus longtemps
en tête mais jusque 2015 c'était c'était
des millions de des millions de
personnes ce donc le fait que miser is
elysées fait en sorte de travailler
entre guillemets travailler au corps le
l'équateur ne semble pas surprenant
malheureusement non
vous parliez d'intérêt
quel pourrait être justement ses
intérêts politiques et diplomatiques
selon vous mais c'est justement toute la
problématique de la liberté de la presse
de la liberté d'expression et du travail
journalistique j'écoutais votre journal
de 20h et l'une de vos journalistes
disaient que tu l'une assange a
certainement été fini d'avoir fait même
trop bien son métier mais finalement
c'est exactement ça pourquoi parce que
le journalisme c'est travailler sur la
vérité des faits et c'est ces couples et
des informations pour être pour être
certain d'atteindre la vérité et
malheureusement les gouvernements n'aime
pas la vérité contrairement à tout ce
qu'on peut nous faire croire
tout ça c'est quand même des révélations
sur dd des informations d'intérêt
général qui ont été d'ailleurs fourni
par des lanceurs dallaire quand des
informations qui ont été vérifiés dont
on connaît les sources et qui prouvent
les manipulation et le mensonge des
états donc forcément ça dérange voyez
bien évidemment et que tout est fait
pour discréditer le messager c'est la
fameuse expression en anglais qui plutôt
que s'occuper du contenu et des
révélations qui ont été faites on
préfère chargé et le messager et lui
trouver toutes les fautes possibles
pistes possibles et inimaginables
mais nos gouvernements en europe enfin
le nouveau gouvernement dans ces
démocraties occidentales sont très très
mal placée
par exemple dans le dernier classement
de reporters sans frontières
la grande bretagne est juste devant la
france la grande bretagne les 33e et
nous les français sommes 34e c'est quand
même une honte pour des pays qui se
disent justement proclamé la liberté
d'expression paul thompson a été
éligible au pal thompson déjà rejoint
vice-président du parti conservateur
britannique en france bonsoir paul
thompson
alors justement c'est votre action vous
à ces informations qui indiquerait que
telle et âmes et aurait joué un rôle
dans l'arrestation de tous les nas anges
je n'ai pas eu à gérer le problème de
connexion et je n'ai pas eu la première
partie de votre échange
malheureusement vous demander de réagir
justement à une possible justement
implication de theresa may dans
l'arrestation de julian assange
je pense que cette le lot g unit et des
états unis sont des alliés très proches
notamment en matière de renseignement
d'information le cajoler un songe un cas
douloureux parce que il
il oppose aux problématiques de liberté
d'expression aux problématiques de
protection des réseaux de renseignements
donc ça crée une forte tension qui est
au coeur du du du sujet si je suis amené
à comparer avec les états unis
je ne trouve pas il y à des pointes
choqué même si on veut dire que le plus
refuser de faire aussi sevani chypre est
ce que vous pensez il faut quand même le
dire en janvier précisé qu'en janvier
dernier 1
la justice britannique a refusé
l'extradition de julian assange vers les
états unis
vous pensez que si theresa may était au
pouvoir aujourd'hui les choses auraient
pu prendre une autre tournure
écoutez je ne pense pas puisque comme le
deal entre autres invités les clair que
les britanniques les américains sont des
puissances alliées et proches donc non
je crois que boris johnson avait donné
des interviewés sur le sujet l'année
dernière de mémoire c'était 2000 2020 et
lui disait que ce qui peut faire lui
s'est améliorée les loin mais il ne peut
pas se positionner sur des cas
particuliers
donc vous voyez quelque part c'est c'est
très hypocrite c'est à dire qu on nous
dit en permanence qu'on ne peut
strictement rien faire c'est pour moi
c'est vraiment une question de plus tôt
même de plus tôt que d'autres de droit
de la presse est aussi une question de
droits de l'homme puisque des rapports
pendant été fait par des experts des
nations unies disant que dieu dans un
sens je souffrais dans cette dans cette
prison de haute sécurité et qu'il était
quelque part mal traitée avec ça lui
posait des problèmes psychologiques donc
on est quand même en gros nous face à
ces questions de de dire que torture
peut être orchestrée par justement un
état qui se dit est un état de droit est
un état qui promeut la liberté
d'expression je trouve ça d'une gravité
inouïe paul thompson qu'est-ce que cela
dit justement sur le respect de la
liberté de la presse au royaume uni
puisque cette décision de ne pas
extrader
d'où les naissances vers les états unis
elle repose principalement sur l'état de
santé l'état psychologique de julian
assange et non pas sur justement la
liberté de la presse
je pense que la liberté de la presse au
royaume uni globalement assurées et
reconnue dans le mouvement est
d'ailleurs il y a des organes de presse
britannique qui sont qui jouit d'une
audience mondiale des économistes bbc et
ça ne vous paraît que tout est parfait
mais ça veut dire qu'il ya une certaine
crédibilité
en ce qui concerne les grands organes de
presse britannique deux cornes aussi qui
est un jour n'a plus de coach a
également une
nommé international et ce depuis
longtemps et donc en ce cas comme je
n'ai déjà dit est un cas politiquement
sensible qui où en est mon estime qu'on
peut être d'un côté ou de l'autre de la
rue mondiaux de documents c'est puissant
td2 gauthé amont à mon avis personnel je
ne pense pas que ce tas est de nature à
ternir leur réputation général du
royaume uni en tant que pays soutien
d'amis watts et de la preuve voulait
répondre c'est fanny stéphanie gibeau là
dessus moi je pense mais je suis pas
tout à fait d'accord parce que je pense
que 1 les les consciences s'éveillent de
on peut voir justement depuis qu'alain
car ces rations un belle marche que
partout dans le monde y ait des
manifestations qui ont lieu par exemple
en belgique il y en a toutes les
semaines on a line toutes les semaines
il y en a dans tous les pays de l'est
couronne britannique que ce soit en
nouvelle zélande en australie bien
évidemment au canada partout des
manifestations de soutien en lieu
justement toujours wikileaks et pour
liberté de julian assange et je pense
que ça commence à intéresser les
citoyens de plus en plus qui sont la
recherche de la vérité à la recherche de
l'information et ce qui est surprenant
justement ans et finalement il est très
très peu de soutien de la part du métier
de journaliste les journalistes eux
mêmes
alors certains prennent la parole est
heureusement bien évidemment
heureusement qu'il ya déjà des soutiens
mais finalement ils sont très peu
nombreux par rapport au nombre de
journalistes
sur le sueur sur l'ensemble de la
planète
donc en fait petit à petit les
consciences s'éveillent et on verra
justement en fonction de ce qui se passe
en appel dans le procès en appel dans
quelques dans quelque temps ce qui va
pouvoir en advenir moi je pense quand
même que c'est très très dommageable
pour pour l'image de la grande-bretagne
justement mais c'est mon avis personnel
alors juste pour conclure paul thompson
s'agissant de la protection des lanceurs
d'alerté au royaume uni où en est-on
rapidement s'il vous plaît à l'eau de la
protection du coin des lanceurs d'alert
des lotions dernière il d'abord il ya un
régime
concernant de le journalisme qui qui
protège le travail ddt des journalistes
il a ensuite il ya un régime en ce qui
concerne les dents se drape dans le
secteur économique qui est un régime
juridique spécifique de relativement
récent qui offrit dans des protections
donc je pense qu'il faut regarder les
cas concrets pour savoir quel régime
joly qui rapplique je ne le leur
le cas de julian assange
rappel une problématique relevant du
journalisme et y est juste un an des
jeux nous sommes revenus au point le
monde en france ont été impliqués a
comme je disais tu déjà au départ c'est
un septième cas très très difficile
parce que des informations intéressantes
ont été dévoilés mais en même temps à
des informations compromettant la vie
des agents de dd renseignements merci
comme des pôles thompson on a vraiment
plus le temps je suis désolé de
vous interromps on n'a plus le temps
d'être vice président du parti
conservateur britannique en france merci
à vous et merci également à stéphanie
hadjibou lanceurs d'alertés également
auteur de la traque des lanceurs
d'alerté prépa c'est justement par
julian assange